Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with David Pepper, who's the former chair
of the Ohio Democratic Party, teaches election
law at University of Cincinnati Law School
and is also author of the book Laboratories
of Autocracy, a wake up call from Behind the
Lines.
It's really great having you on, David.
Speaker 4: Thank you.
It's good to be with you.
Speaker 1: So, yeah, I think maybe to start
with, there's so many different places where
we could look and talk about autocracy.
Authoritarian tendencies and beyond.
Sometimes people talk about voter disenfranchisement
and suppression techniques at the state level.
We obviously have this big national story
of the multi-pronged effort to take an election
that they didn't actually win in November
of 2020.
There's all these different things of control
of school curricula.
I mean, when you look at autocracy, what are
the most concerning kind of bullet points
that you start with?
Speaker 4: So I'd say my biggest concern is
that we focus on some of the most prominent
people like Trump and we should.
But my biggest worry is the other side that
has, you know, some of the players have been
at this for a long time.
And while we focus on the high profile people
and the things that make a lot of noise in
the bright, shiny objects like a large hail
of green, they're focused on the institutions
that either support democracy or, if weakened,
could usher in, you know, the lack of democracy,
or ultimately something that I think is referred
to often as competitive autocracy.
And the reason I wrote the book is to say,
you know, it reminds me of the movie Don't
look up, which I was at first afraid to watch,
but then glad I did it saying, don't only
look at Washington.
The institutions that shape our democracy
in so many ways are states.
One side figured that out a long time ago.
They have a minority view.
They can only survive in a world without robust
democracy.
So they've had their eye and tentacles on
the states for a long time, and they're converting
them into.
As I describe laboratories of autocracy that
are nonstop, undermining key, you know, principles
and tenets and protections for democracy.
And it's accelerating.
And so it's sort of look at the institutions
don't just look at our usual politics, which
is, you know, federal majorities won through
swing districts and swing states.
Look at the institutions that shape democracy.
Those are largely statehouses.
Yes, the federal government can do important
things to protect against those they must.
But the heart of it is at the state level.
And I just think one side has been blind to
that for a generation.
The other side has been focused on it like
a laser and our scoring victory after a victory.
Because of that.
Speaker 1: So competitive autocracy, competitive
authoritarianism, that's a term I've used
with my audience before this.
This is important to understand this is that
you have at least I say in theory, but maybe
some people would say in principle democratic
institutions and electoral competition, but
it's not really fair competition.
Is that generally the gist of it?
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's it's it's rigging things
in advance.
It's minority rule locked in with a veneer
of legitimacy, with the with the illusion
that everything was fair and up for grabs.
And you know, it sounds very sort of that's
that's quite an accusation.
But we know what it looks like.
It looks like hungry.
And so we make this accusation.
It's not really rebuttable anymore because
they're all going to hungry, celebrating it
in the wide open, you know?
Tucker Carlson, C-PAC, Trump, you know, endorsing
Auburn.
They're not hiding the competitive autocracy
system that that, you know, we see in other
countries.
Is that what they want when they embrace Hungary?
And is I as I go through the book, almost
every element that Hungary is going through
rigging legislative elections, suppressing
votes in the opposition party, attacking courts,
almost every element that Hungary, you know,
go through the checklist is going through.
You could overlay in the State House after
State House in our country.
It's the same pattern.
So it's not like they're only celebrating
it in twenty twenty two, it's either they've
been modeling off of it or just doing the
same thing on their own for years.
And so, yeah, it's it is what it is, the model.
And that's why I think one of the reasons
I wrote the book is not simply to say here
the elements of it that we should be concerned
about, but we have to move away from doing
things that unintentionally legitimize it
all.
And when we're too silent, when we when we
treat it as politics, as normal, by applying,
by allowing the filibuster to stop us from
stopping it, by treating it like any other
issue, we play into the, you know, the competitive
autocracy end goal, which is not only to serve.
Democracy, but to make everyone think that
it's it actually still is there in a viable
way.
Speaker 1: That's a good point, right?
Because if
Speaker 4: people don't seem legitimate, if
Speaker 1: people believe it's legitimate,
they are less likely to rise up against it.
Speaker 4: Correct.
And it sustains for much longer.
But you know, again, what is not an effective,
competitive autocracy storming a building
that was not what you do?
That was literally, I'm sure Auburn was like,
no, that does not look legitimate.
The key to my success is not openly, you know,
trying to overturn an election.
It's actually just suddenly predetermined
outcomes.
Everyone votes and you wipe your hand and
say, Hey, look, election happened.
I won again for the tenth time, even though
I'm in the minority.
So, so that's why I think we, you know in
some, may not like this.
But that's why I thought it was good.
When those Texas legislators left Texas, they
were declaring this illegitimate.
You don't normally leave your state.
I wouldn't recommend that.
But if something is so illegitimate, then
if you just sit there and vote no and it passes,
the voters may think, Well, that's just politics
is normal.
It's reaching a point where I think people
who are fighting for democracy have to call
this out, and that's why you get to meet the
Senate needs to keep amping it up.
Joe Biden can't go silent again.
If we if we have to force Chuck Grassley and
Josh Hawley and Cruz to debate for two weeks
on end to stop our our votes to protect democracy,
great.
Make them do it because competitive autocracy
relies on a sense that it's legitimate and
normal.
We know it's not, but I think too rarely do
we actually act in that way, which is allowing
it to continue.
Speaker 1: So one of the discussions that
I often have with people who watch my show
with other guests or whoever really is, to
what extent do you focus on changing the system
versus using the system to our advantage?
And the prototypical example is the gerrymandering
redistricting, which is right.
Obviously, I would rather and many of the
people in my audience would rather a system
to prevent gerrymandering to begin with, whether
it's a nonpartisan redistricting commission,
whatever, whatever the way it is, you prevent
the problem.
But until that happens, is there any choice
but to take every opportunity to gerrymander
for your side because otherwise they're going
to gerrymander?
How do you strike this balance in is?
Speaker 4: Is it a great question?
Yeah, I mean, gerrymandering is bad no matter
what I try and show in the book and I go through
my book one way to think about it.
I do hope everyone gets it because no interview
can sort of get into the details.
Sure.
And I wrote it to be read and share because
I'm so alarmed.
But I think of my book is sort of what's the
matter with Kansas, with a lot of focus on
Ohio.
But the point is about democracy itself.
And I walk through that once you have the
non-democratic world of gerrymandering where
no one's accountable and this is going to
be true for anyone who does it, although they
do a lot worse than we do.
This is not a both sides issue public outcomes
crater in these non-democratic, rigged statehouses
because the incentives that we normally expect
on politicians and democracy, good public
outcomes don't be corrupt.
All the account, all the incentives that come
with the accountability democracy disappear
in these rig systems.
So Ohio, under this terribly rigged, non-democratic
State House has seen our educate, our public
education, fail our health care outcomes in
the low 40s, highest level student debt in
the country.
So no one should be stuck in a state house
with no democracy.
It's just bad, but to your point.
There's going to be a natural race to the
bottom if one side sees one doing it, especially
the congressional level.
And if they don't do it, then they lose power.
And this is why it doesn't have to be either
or this is why the federal legislation that
would provide guardrails for everybody is
so important.
And I want everything there to pass.
But but the legislation in the Freedom the
Vote Act would basically come up with some
rules about what an unconstitutional gerrymander
looks like or an illegal gerrymander in the
federal law.
It may not be deemed unconstitutional, but
it could be deemed illegal.
That would basically say whether whatever
state you are, there certain rules you have
to follow it, you're violating the law and
the Congress has the right to do that.
That's the best way to avoid what you talked
about, change the system, add guardrails and
don't put any state in a position that that
it's creating basically a lack of democracy
in all the terrible results they come.
And by the way, we in Ohio, we did pass two
constitutional amendments.
We elected a fair Supreme Court.
We showed in the last couple of weeks that
a court will uphold fair rules if if you have
them in place, and that's why the court struck
down a really bad map here.
That's a win for democracy the best in the
last generation Ohio.
But it shows that that federal legislation
could do the same thing.
So there's a way to avoid that, that terrible
choice by establishing rules that that everyone
has to follow up.
Speaker 1: Many in our audience understand
and are aware of the push to privatization
that exists in a number of different areas
in society.
In the book, you talk about how a lot of that
is actually happening thanks to state legislatures.
Can you give a couple examples of that?
Because I think oftentimes the assumption
is that it's happening as a result of things
that politicians in Washington, D.C. are doing
now.
Speaker 4: So the big private players have
figured out over the last 20 years.
To get the worst, hairiest, most unpopular
and most inconsistent with public outcomes.
Parts of their agenda done.
You go to the state houses.
That's where you do it because no one's paying
attention.
These people are rigged so they can ever lose
their election, even when they do really stupid
and horrible things.
And so examples of that in Ohio, they drain
public schools of funding for a generation
to give it to for profit charter school online
outfits, some of which have been total scams.
And the politicians, even though the schools
in their own backyards are plummeting and
have less money and the public and the and
the private players they've helped who have
given the money the whole time have literally
turned into scandals.
They've only won because of it.
They've never lost.
So that's a great example.
In Ohio, we've been draining money.
We, the statehouse has been pulling money
out of local governments for a decade to give
it out as tax cuts at the high end.
The entire trickle down theory is in play
in almost every state.
Again, it would not be sustainable.
The shape of small towns and school districts
is collapsing.
It wouldn't be sustainable in a normal democracy
because the results are indefensible.
But in this rigged world where they can't
lose, these players have figured out you couldn't
get it done in Washington.
It's too hard.
But in it and it get it, get coverage in a
way that that would be a problem, right?
But that Betsy DeVos agenda, a State House
will do it without thinking twice.
And for the most part, no one even knows their
examples of all over the country and in what
am I advice pieces of advice in my book to
anyone running?
Don't talk about most of what we're talking
about right now in your 30 second general
election ad.
Fine.
The public outcome that is the most horrific.
In Kansas, it was the fact that they had school
four days a week, right?
And Laura Kelly won on that issue.
She could have said anything in the world
about Kris Kobach.
Did a lot of Democrats who might have said,
we agree.
But she was smart enough to say the true issue
where I can explain the impact of this corruption
and this privatization of everything at the
state level and how it impacts public outcomes
people care about.
The best example a school four days a week
in Texas.
It's an energy grid collapsing so that people
froze to death a year ago, and Beto O'Rourke
is doing a great job on that.
Focusing on that, it's we have to translate
the the corrosion of the public asset, public
good and the common good is endemic to these
broken, privatized state houses.
And we have to be smart enough to not just,
you know, run around saying the sky is falling,
although it arguably is falling quickly, is
to say the reason you everyday voters should
care about this is your town and your school
and your roads and everything else are in
worse shape because the Koch brothers have
essentially taken over your State House
Speaker 1: in the in the just minute we have
left other than registering to vote and voting
in every election where you can vote.
What are the what's the low hanging fruit
that people in the audience should be doing?
Speaker 4: It's got broader and then registering,
although that's a very important part of it
in states like George in Ohio.
Think about your footprint that you have of
influence and think about all the ways that
you can use that footprint to lift democracy,
and it's bigger than you imagined.
If you're on the board of a homeless shelter,
is the homeless shelter engaging those it
serves or a food bank?
Do you know the mayor of a town?
Are they registering voters in their rec centers,
in their libraries?
Scale it up if you run a small business is
part of your mission of that business.
Lift democracy.
And again, it's registration.
It's engagement.
Once people are registered, it's early vote.
Just think Larry, sit down and write down,
what's my footprint?
And I go through all the details in the book
and and engage that footprint as much as you
can to look democracy.
And that includes helping people run for state
office, State House Office, Board of Education,
you name it, registering.
But use your footprint.
Don't wait for Stacey Abrams to save the day
or Michelle Obama.
Don't just assume people are going to get
registered to the rear motor vehicles.
Use the things you do every day to also live
democracy.
And that's the way I think we start hitting
a scale, especially when we know that every
single day the other side is attacking those
same voters and attacking democracy.
So if you're not doing this stuff, we're not
just holding steady, we're losing ground in
a lot of these states.
Speaker 1: Without a doubt, the book is Laboratories
of Autocracy, a wake up call from behind the
lines.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
David Pepper.
David, really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 4: Thank you.
Great talking to you.
Thanks for all you talk about every day.